okay let's try our caller from the 71
for area code caller from 71 for a tell
us your name and where you're calling
from and what's on your mind today hey
my name is Laura I'm in Orange County
California I was wondering what you
think about the story from The
Washington Post it says that
non-citizens can now vote in College
Park Maryland and my follow-up to that
is why do so many people on the Left
think that voter ID laws are racist well
there's a couple different things in
there the first story you mentioned I've
not seen so I don't I would not be able
to comment on it because I've not seen
that story but I'll look into it Laura
your second question was why do so many
people on the Left believe that voter ID
laws are racist so let's expand on that
a little bit like who who specifically
are you talking about and what have they
said I'm talking about people on CNN I'm
talking about the ACLU having a legal
battle with the state of Texas saying
that the requirement that you show ID is
such a horrible thing it's so difficult
for people to show ID before voting
but people show ID to buy alcohol and to
go to the movies mm-hmm now Laura you
first said that it was that there were
people on the Left saying that voter ID
is racist but now you're saying that the
ACLU is saying that it's difficult for
people to show ID so those are two
different arguments right who says the
cou on CNN said voter ID is racist well
it's it's a talking point that I've
heard on CNN and but from who probably
god lemon
you probably heard on CNN from Don Lemon
that voter ID is racist one of the
people he was interviewing oh so it
wasn't Don Lemon who said it it was
somebody else it was his program but it
was you know so it was a guests opinion
you're saying okay well listen here's
the thing Laura a lot of this kind of
gets wrapped up in semantics right where
if we say something is racist or
something disproportionately impacts
people who are
member of a particular members of a
particular race so it's a lot of it gets
wrapped up in the sort of semantics of
it but here's my view on the entire
voter ID thing right because at
face-value you're right listen you show
ID to buy alcohol you show ID to prove
you're old enough to get into a rated R
movie
what about showing an ID to get in to
vote the problem I have is the following
it's not that showing ID is a difficult
task but the issue is that so-called
free voter IDs aren't really free in the
sense that depending on where you live
and depending on what your family
background is or was in terms of
economic situation and other factors in
order to get a so-called voter ID you
might have to travel you might have to
travel and there are costs associated
with that and not only that once you get
to where you need to get the voter ID
you might be required to show documents
to get the voter ID that are not free
documents to obtain and if you've had
for example anything from housing into
instability to parental instability or
any other number of sort of issues
throughout your life you would not have
those documents and then you would also
have to pay to obtain those documents
and in addition to that the people who
would most have trouble getting time off
from their job during what we would call
business hours Monday through Friday 9
to half 9 to 5 are disproportionately
economically disadvantaged people which
in our country happen to be more likely
to be not white so it's very easy to
just say there's nothing racist about
saying show me an ID but when you
actually go through the mechanics in the
large numbers of well what does it mean
to get a so-called free ID you can see
how it would disproportionately impact
members of a certain race so whether you
call it racist or not is sort of it's a
semantic argument but do you sort of
understand the the path I'm walking
through here yeah I get it I guess
there's the obstacles to obtaining the
ID right yes
right Laura well listen I hope that my
comments have been helpful to you I
really really appreciate the call we
will take a break and then we will
continue with more of your calls after
this